what's going on guys this is rob and
with the celestials taking center stage
in the marvel cinematic universe and
giving us an actual mcu depiction of the
celestials that we know from the comics
beyond you know the simple flashback
from guardians of the galaxy i thought
it'd be cool to go back and rework our
celestials explained video and the
reason for this is because those are the
guys who saw that original video about
12 minutes long or so a lot of things
have changed in marvel since then and
really the work of al ewing's ultimates
totally restructured and gave us a far
more in-depth explanation of what the
celestials are capable of but just for
the sake of posterity i do kind of want
to explain a little bit the way things
used to be if for no other reason than
the fact that when you're standing in
line in a movie theater you can be like
actually the way the celestials used to
be was like this
uh but the idea here it really comes
from a couple different places the most
notable is exactly the same place that
we referenced in the old video being
astonishing x-men volume 3 issue number
61. now at the time what you had was
basically this explanation that the
celestials were there at the beginning
of the universe and that in effect when
it came to marvel the only universe you
really had was the main marvel universe
now the biggest issue with this
explanation is that we know from the old
thor comics and the initial origin of
galactus that there was a universe
before the current universe but the
reason why this was such a big deal is
because the explanation given here was
that at the beginning of the universe
the celestials were seemingly the only
things in existence they had created
life but they also sought to create
death now while these things are never
really given a name all we're told is
that the celestials created this kind of
organic object organic race that was
like a sentient embodiment of death
ultimately they turned on the celestials
and because the celestials could not
actually destroy them they created the
multiverse and then locked these things
away in a singular universe now again we
already knew the multiverse existed and
there wasn't really any attempt by
marvel at the time to take this whole
idea and consolidate it with our
existing knowledge of the multiverse's
existence marvel offered this idea that
the celestials created the multiverse
and that was basically it the other part
of this was that again kind of citing
that old information during the secret
origin of tony stark's storyline during
kieran gillan's run on iron man one of
the things that was told to us was that
at some point in the universe's early
history there was a war that broke out
between the aspirants and the celestials
and the celestials ultimately won
despite the fact that the aspirants had
created something called the god killer
armor right just this insanely enormous
suit of armor that was capable of
destroying celestials and they almost
won the funny thing about this was that
at the time that was written and we even
talked about this during ultimates at
the time that was written that was all
we got we didn't really get any
information beyond that initial
explanation given to us and just kind of
had to just sort of roll with it one of
the things that happened when it came to
al ewing's run on ultimates is he
consolidated a ton of information
belonging to the celestials some of
which he eliminated some of which he
kept and then also introduced a host of
new stuff so what i want to do here is i
want to kind of give you guys this new
updated origin of the celestials as they
exist in marvel comics right now and
then we'll go through our normal fare of
our character team explanations with
their history and all that kind of stuff
so the way this played out in the
ultimate comics written by al ewing is
that before anything existed you had the
one above all and for whatever reason
which is never explained to us the one
above all created what was called the
first firmament you can also call it the
first universe but in essence the first
universe was basically sentient in the
same way that eternity is sentient right
so eternity is a representation of what
would happen if the universe could get
up and walk around that the first
firmament predates all of that right
there was no eternity no none of that
stuff it was just the first universe and
the result was that the first universe
due to loneliness as is explained ended
up basically creating what were called
the aspirants and the aspirants were
these enormously powerful beings that
were by all standards of measurement the
celestials as you know them now the big
difference here is that the aspirants
basically sought the approval of the
first universe whenever they created
anything right so solar systems and
galaxies and stars and when they created
life on worlds and different things like
that if the first firmament was
satisfied with what they'd done it would
just continue on if the first firmament
was dissatisfied the aspirants would
destroy it and then they would start all
over again now while the aspirants were
doing that there was actually a smaller
group of aspirants that broke off that
basically deviated away from the role
that was assigned to them by the first
firmament under the belief that the
first firm in itself and life and
everything else should learn to
understand growth change and mortality
meaning they should experience what it
means to die and to be reborn as
something better than what they were
before the result of this is that they
were in effect calling on the death of
the universe which was taken to be
something that was basically heresy and
so this led to what we call the
celestial holy war or the cosmic holy
war and this was essentially a giant war
between the celestials and the aspirins
now what we're talking about here is a
war between beings that have the power
to basically do anything they want in a
universe right to create life to destroy
life to create galaxies all that kind of
stuff so as you guys can imagine this
war was pretty extreme and in fact it
was so intense that this is when the
aspirants developed the god killer armor
for a time the aspirants were winning
they were going to come out on top and
they were going to defeat the celestials
but for reasons that are never explained
to us the aspirants themselves fell into
a civil war what this did is it allowed
the celestials to capitalize on that
detonate these gigantic cosmic bombs
they had which not only destroyed what
was left of the aspirants but actually
shattered the first firmament into an
infinite number of pieces and that's the
explanation of the multiverse following
that what you had was essentially the
second cosmos if you can consider the
first firmament to be the first cosmos
and that basically led to the celestials
as the only survivors of the first
universe who literally inhabited just
this gigantic empty space they started
spreading into the multiverse itself and
so that's how you end up getting
celestials and like the ultimate
universe in marvel comics then you get
the celestials in the main marvel
universe and that's how you see them in
every universe that exists out there but
following this what you had was the
pattern of universes that would die and
be reborn both through natural and
unnatural means natural means is just
the heat death of the universe it
expands out until it reaches the point
where it can't expand any further then
it contracts and then it experiences
what we call the big crunch then it dies
it converts into a singularity and then
explodes back outward again in a big
bang the multiverse experienced the
exact same thing now we're not given any
information in terms of the different
iterations of the multiverses insofar as
why they were destroyed we can largely
assume that it just leads to a handful
of different things but for the
celestials themselves they were both
killed and reborn each time these
universes were killed and reborn and
each time the multiverse was killed and
reborn the only real exception to this
seems to come by way of both the king
and black as well as the first story arc
of donnie kate's run on thor and the
reason why i say that is because during
the first run on thor that donnie kate's
had he introduced something called the
black winter that if galactus travels
around the universe consuming
life-sustaining worlds that the black
winter traveled around the multiverse
consuming entire universes and it's kind
of a weird thing here because this is
kind of left to us as an explanation for
why galactus's universe was destroyed in
the first place in the old comics
adventures of the x-men back in the
1990s early 2000s it was actually the
result of a being called the dweller in
darkness right who basically tried to
destroy the multiverse so he can merge
with it and be reborn as god it didn't
work but the multiverse ended up
collapsing anyway the important thing
here is that what this story seemed to
indicate is that where we would look at
the various beings of any one particular
universe and that they would essentially
perish in that universe's destruction
the celestials seem to outlive that the
celestials actually seem to survive the
destruction of universes and then enter
into universes and the reason why is
because this goes into donnie kate's the
king and black event which focused on
null and the way this is explained and
it's really more of a contextual thing
as opposed to him actually saying the
celestials always survive the death of a
universe what we ended up learning was
that following the destruction of the
sixth universe at the hands of uh of the
black winter that the celestials existed
in this vast empty space now it looks as
though and we're not really giving this
explanation here it looks as though
their existence in this space predated
that of like eternity infinity all those
cosmic entities that you consider to be
synonymous with any one particular
universe but the important thing here is
that what they did in what we call the
seventh universe or the universe that
existed in marvel comics prior to the
events of secret wars 2015 is that they
began to create life now this was a big
caveat because at that time this space
was occupied by a being called null who
of course wanted to become the symbiote
god the guy who created the symbiotes
venom and all those different characters
but because the celestials were
basically creating life it was like they
walked into his home and just started
remodeling it right i mean how happy
would you be if somebody walked into
your house and then just started
remodeling your living room
it would piss you off except instead of
null yelling at them he created what was
called the all black necro sword killed
a celestial or at least chopped its head
off which is actually where the space
station of nowhere comes from in marvel
comics and then used the energy of that
dead celestial to imbue it to his necro
sword to basically amass its power and
to make it this insanely capable weapon
uh which in turn he used to wage war
against the other celestials now the
celestials of course ended up defeating
noah basically locked him away he was
trapped by his own symbiotes inside of a
world and that was basically that but
then you went into a story that was
called infinity wars which was an
absolutely terrible story this one
wasn't hugely important and in fact a
lot of what we know about the celestials
and the infinity stones is really more
inferred here than anything else just
because of the fact that a lot of people
say that during this story it was
solidified or established that the
infinity stones came into existence with
the multiverse itself and that what the
celestials did is they took the infinity
stones and put them in individual
universes there really isn't anything to
say that in fact the line that people
usually use for that is an offhanded
remark made by loki when he asked them
when are you guys going to stop chucking
infinity stones into our universes right
that's usually what people use so you
can take that as a truth if you want to
honestly i wouldn't really argue and
really wouldn't say that the celestials
were responsible for the infinity stones
entering into any particular universe i
find it more interesting to believe that
the infinity stones come into existence
with the creation of a universe because
they represent the different aspects of
a universe but regardless another major
change regarding the history of the
celestials in marvel comics actually
came by way of jason aaron's run on
avengers and this introduces something
called the progenitor celestial or the
fallen and that's what you want to call
them now this was a particularly
interesting change that jason aaron
implemented because prior to this in
fantastic four volume one issue number
316 the development of life on other
worlds was largely attributed to a race
called the fortescuens that had been
created by the beyonders themselves and
their goal was to quite literally see
life throughout the universe now this
seemed to kind of fly in the face of
conventional wisdom which while it
didn't necessarily solidify it as truth
had largely just been argued that the
celestials were the ones who created
everything but regardless of whether or
not you follow that ideology during
jason aaron's run on avengers what you
had were the celestials and then you had
a group called the horde now the
introduction of the horde was largely
based off the works of neil gaiman and
charles noth during their eternals runs
and the idea here is that the celestials
themselves represent life whereas the
horde represents death and both groups
serve a being called the fulcrum who may
or may not be the one above all marvel
never really clarifies but the idea is
that when a world is experimented on by
the celestials themselves which we'll
talk about here in a minute and that
life kind of progresses for a period of
time they call it 19 cosmic cycles they
don't really provide a direct one-to-one
comparison in terms of what that means
here in the real world uh but once that
period is over if the life force of that
energy is more in line with the deviance
meaning it's more violent uh more more
primitive so on and so forth then that
life force goes to the horde if the life
force is more in line with the eternals
meaning that it has achieved a kind of
higher state of enlightenment than it
goes to the celestials the reason why
this matters is because it basically
tied into the nature of the horde
themselves insofar as there came a point
when one of the celestials whose name is
never really given to us he's simply
referred to as the progenitor is
basically attacked by the horde now the
horde don't usually consume celestials
but because of the fact that they rely
on energy in order to exist where they
normally stick to worlds if things are
dire enough
they'll consume celestials and that's
what had happened there and so the
progenitor had actually crash-landed on
earth and then it's inside what you
could call blood had basically permeated
the earth itself and that's what led to
the emergence of life on earth the other
part of this is that where it was
previously believed that the celestials
arriving on earth and modifying the
genes of early man was largely due to
the fact that this was just the next
stop in their grand universal experiment
of modifying life across worlds that
jason aaron's run actually established
that the celestials showed up on earth
because they were hunting for the
progenitor they didn't know what
happened to him once they discovered
that he'd basically been consumed by the
horde well there wasn't really anything
they could do right they ended up just
confining the horde inside earth and
then they in turn basically created the
eternals the deviants and then what
would eventually become super powered
beings now this is something that we've
talked about so many times before but it
is the celestials explained so we have
to explain it again
of course if you don't want to stick
through this you're welcome to skip
ahead but the idea behind this is that
the celestials always visit worlds in
four hosts the first host is them
showing up and then basically modifying
the genetic structure of that planet's
race into three distinct groups or three
distinct races if you want to call them
that the first one is basically a race
that has their genes modified so they
will essentially become almost angelic
or god-like beings they are by all
standards of measurement immortal
meaning they can never die of like
illness or disease you can physically
kill them but a machine system is
basically put in place to ensure they
can always be resurrected that group is
referred to as the eternals the second
group has their genes destabilized to
create unchecked mutations meaning
anything can happen and the celestials
don't really pay much attention to what
does happen it's just kind of like
whatever happens happens and they call
it a day that group ends up becoming the
deviants the third group will have their
genes modified so that at some future
point in time those genes will start
manifesting and basically developing
powers that's the explanation marvel
gives us in terms of one where mutants
come from and two why it is that
different individuals can be subjected
to like radiation treatments so like
banner being blasted with a gamma bomb
or steve rogers being injected with a
super soldier serum and blasted with
vitarase and they go on to basically
develop powers instead of just turning
into like a giant mass of tumors and
then ultimately dying or exploding or
something along those lines now this
form and function this type of
experiment right the eternals the
deviants and then just baseline
modifications that will manifest later
on that's every single world so it's
been done to the cree it's been done to
the scrolls it's been done to everybody
or at least every major race that exists
out there in some cases like the scrolls
the deviants actually went out in some
cases like the cree it ends up being the
eternal variance that ended up winning
out regarding earth it was really more
the eternals and the humans who
basically won out now the way this
worked out because the deviants were
really just such a much larger number
than the eternals were and the eternals
given the power they had didn't really
care about anything this led to the
deviants actually conquering humanity
and then setting up a capital city in
lumeria on the kingdom of atlantis and
so where this became like a massive
trading port right just kind of a huge
hub you had some technological
advancements different things like that
a war broke out between the eternals and
the deviants not because of the fact the
deviants had enslaved humanity even
though the eternals were tasked with
safeguarding humans instead what ended
up happening is that the deviants struck
first against the eternals in order to
destroy them and so when this war broke
out you actually saw the eternals
essentially losing there were just too
many deviants out there who were just
too strong and so in a last-ditch effort
the eternals contacted the celestials
who basically be turned in the second
host and once the celestials arrived the
deviants immediately attacked the
celestials the celestials of course
basically eradicated the deviants or at
least pushed them to the point where
their numbers that were previously in
the millions were dwindled down to a few
thousand they also initiated something
called the great cataclysm which was
basically the sinking of atlantis and so
that's why the the deviants ended up
taking underground now following that
the celestials actually turned to the
eternals and they realized that humanity
was conquered by the deviants because
the eternals had ignored their role of
safeguarding humanity and so the
eternals were warned should that ever
happen again the celestials will destroy
them they'll wipe out everything on
earth and they'll start over and so that
basically led to the eternals becoming
more involved in the affairs of humanity
because they just didn't want to be
destroyed now something else that had
also happened during this time was the
imprisonment of tiamou the dreaming
celestial so while you did have a whole
bunch of celestials there irish and the
judge different people like that what
you had here was tiamu who was
technically the communicator and while
tiamu had created a few uh eternals and
deviants of his own design that would
serve their own unique purpose makari
for example being one of them that when
the time came when the celestials had
shown back up on earth and they had
found that the deviants had conquered
the world the normal practice was that
they would cleanse the earth everything
would be destroyed that life energy
would be sent to the fulcrum and because
it was more in line with the deviants it
would be sent to the horde instead what
happened is irish and the judge had
judged in such a way to where only the
deviants would be punished and so this
basically led tiamu to believe that
essentially the celestials were acting
outside of their quote unquote
programming or prescribed role and so he
turned against irish and the judge only
to be attacked by the rest of the
celestials which basically stripped him
of his life essence put his body below
the ground and then put his life essence
in something called the vile and the
dreaming celestial had basically just
stayed there for a millennia something
like a million years until he was
ultimately woken up during neil gaiman's
run on the eternals now beyond that the
celestial's actions in terms of what
they do out there in the universe is
never really known to us the only time
we ever really see anything regarding
what the celestials do is whenever they
interact with people on earth and it
makes sense right marvel comics is a
series of stories told from the
perspective of people on earth most of
the time sometimes there's people from
space right so like they're going into
the galaxy richard ryder and the nova
corps different things like that but the
closest that we got here was actually
during uh x-men vol 2 issue number 186
and this actually dealt with a villain
named apocalypse right so some of you
guys have heard of insabon noor or at
least everybody who's been on my channel
for a while has knows who that guy is
but some of you guys who are not
familiar with my channel have maybe
never heard of him insabon noor is
largely considered to be the first real
external mutant to come into existence
but external mutants are basically
mutants who are like eternals in the
sense that they are legitimately
immortal but a big difference here is
that unlike eternals if you were to cut
off the head of an external and then you
were to simply just sit their head on
their neck their healing factor would
kick in and they would come back to life
with eternals it doesn't really work
that way they can just be resurrected by
the machine so it's like their own
little caveat going on there but the
idea is that for most of his existence
apocalypse had tried to make contact
with a celestial ship and tried to find
some way to interface with his
technology it never really worked it
wasn't until cable from the future went
into the past to try to destroy
apocalypse failed but cable's
techno-organic virus had infiltrated
apocalypse and then given apocalypse the
ability to infiltrate with machines that
he was finally able to do it when this
took place he was met by issan the
searcher and while it is a little bit
ambiguous all that was really told here
was that apocalypse would be given the
ability to utilize celestial technology
but that quote unquote future payments
would be required later right we didn't
really know what that meant and we still
don't know what it means we know he was
taken away by the celestials at one
point but we don't know what really
happened the results of this is that
coming out of that experience apocalypse
had become basically a demigod he had
used celestial technology to essentially
modify his body so he could basically do
anything he wanted to right he could
give himself virtually any superhuman
power and do virtually anything shy of
reality warping on any real scale now
following that you go into the first
century this is one of the most
important things when it comes to the
celestials is that when you look at
stories like earth x one of the things
that was established is that celestials
procreate by basically planting their
eggs or their seeds inside worlds and
that when the time comes when that
celestial egg is able to basically be
born it emerges from that world and it
destroys the world in the process the
role galactus plays is traveling around
the cosmos consuming life-sustaining
worlds in order to keep the celestial
population in check now for years that
was a earth x concept it was locked away
in earth x and that was it that was the
only universe where it happened it
wasn't until jonathan hickman's shield
and the celestial madonna that that
basically changed that the celestial
madonna was is not really to be confused
with mantis like not really that story
but the celestial madonna was basically
a celestial that was pregnant with
offspring and that wasn't really
supposed to happen instead as it was
explained here celestials normally
deposit their life essence in worlds in
order to be born and so that was
basically jonathan hickman taking the
earth x concept rolling it into the main
marvel universe and going forward from
there you never really see it happen and
in fact i can't really think of an
occasion where i've seen an instance
where celestial's been born uh in the
center of a life-sustaining world and
then emerged and destroyed that world in
the process again i've never really
heard of that or at least i've never
actually seen it happen maybe it has i
don't know and honestly it's not really
important if it does but the celestial's
really arrival on earth happened again
during the third host and this took
place in thor issue number 300 and this
was basically a story where it had come
to the attention of the celestials that
a lot of the godly beings out there what
we call the sky fathers so zeus and odin
and vishnu and those guys had gotten
themselves involved in the affairs of
mortal men so that humanity actually
started worshiping them as gods and so
because of the fact that this had the
potential to alter the the really
evolutionary structure of humanity or
the evolutionary direction of humanity
that the celestial showed up and
essentially warned the sky fathers not
to interfere now this led to the sky
fathers bringing in something called the
destroyer armor under the belief that it
could destroy the celestials it didn't
work and the celestials almost killed
the sky fathers and so with that kind of
message being sent
the sky fathers were like okay and that
was marvel's explanation for why it is
that humanity had believed in zeus and
odin and those guys traveled around with
humanity and humanity interacted with
them and then suddenly one day they
didn't but it was just kind of a way to
sort of explain those things and why it
happened nonetheless the final and
really more recent arrival of the
celestials on earth in the form of a
host i mean they have kind of appeared
here and there but in the form of a host
actually came during the 20th century
and again this was covered during the
events of thor issue number 300 and the
idea here was that when the celestials
had arrived it was basically their final
judgment that the fourth host represents
the point at which the celestials arrive
on that particular planet they judge the
evolution of that world and they decide
if it should live or if it should die
and so with the entirety of the
celestial host encased inside an
indestructible dome there was no real
way for anybody to get to them the
closest you got was actually a coming
together of odin thor and the eternals
who could do nothing to the to the
celestials
they couldn't hurt them or anything
ultimately it actually ended up being
gaia the sentience of mother earth who
presented 12 individuals out there that
were basically or at least believed to
be the fruition of the celestial's
experiments basically saying these
individuals are what you've been looking
for with regards to this grand
experiment that you engaged in
ultimately the celestials were satisfied
and ended up basically leaving now
following that the celestial's emergence
of arrival on earth only ever really
came when there was like some kind of a
big calamity right so the rise of the
dreaming celestial and the celestials
coming back in order to deal with him
different things along those lines and
this again went back into the events of
x-men extermination which again really
kind of gave us the initial explanation
of the celestials it's just one of these
things where like they just kind of
appeared here and there more often than
not it's really more the power of the
celestials that manifest in some form or
fashion now outside of that one of the
big things you saw there are actually a
few huge things you saw with those
celestials that didn't directly
interfere with earth the most notable of
these is obviously the events of
infinity gauntlet right thanos getting
the infinity stones forming the infinity
gauntlet and this was just one of those
things where the story didn't
specifically focus on the celestials as
much as it did the celestials alongside
pretty much all the other cosmic
entities trying to find a way to defeat
thanos ultimately it didn't work a lot
of those stories were like that a lot of
the space-faring stories with dan abner
and those guys you saw some escapades
involving the celestials there but again
none of those stories really focus on
the celestial specifically it's just the
celestials were there during those
particular campaigns now one of the more
interesting things involving the
celestials actually came during the
events of time runs out during the
events of jonathan hickman's avengers
and new avengers and the reason why this
mattered is because what you had was the
collapse of the multiverse and while it
wasn't just the celestials you also had
galactus and a few other people that
what you had here were the beyonders who
were basically uh cutting a swath
through the whole multiverse and killing
cosmic entities everywhere they found
them and that's why you ended up seeing
reed richards and black panther and the
other members of the superhero community
calling together the the cosmic entities
and then suddenly the cosmic entities
just left because at that point the
actions of the beyonders required their
help now what you also ended up finding
out is that during the early days of the
incursions reed richards of the
fantastic four had sent hank pym ant-man
into the multiverse to find out what was
causing the collapse only for hank pym
to come across the beyonders killing the
celestials and all the cosmic entities
in one universe and then realizing they
were doing it across the whole
multiverse ultimately coalescing in them
destroying the living tribunal so again
you know it's one of these things where
the celestials appearing in these
various stories really dealt more with
them just kind of appearing for a moment
being part of a series of events in more
recent years you saw noel the symbiote
god re-emerging during the events of
king and black showing up on earth and
then actually having conscripted the
celestials into his service and
conscription's probably not even the
best description it was more like he
enslaved them like he took them over and
enslaved them into his service it was
kind of nuts but the reality is that
when it comes to the celestials and
marvel comics you don't really see very
many instances when stories focus
explicitly on them right so you don't
really see like celestials volume one
the celestial's volume two but you don't
really see anything like that instead
it's usually the celestials having some
kind of involvement with humanity and
then doing something that requires them
to be there or there's just some kind of
massive conflict or something along
those lines the thing that celestials
are most known for are the various hosts
they engage in right when they show up
on earth for modifying the genes of
early man judging them that kind of a
thing that's really what the celestials
are known best for but beyond that it's
usually just them kind of appearing in a
few stories here and there but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end we're at like 31
minutes before edits so thank you guys
for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace